this is what
india's second coronavirus wave looks
like
the mortuaries simply don't have space
for all the bodies
as the global death toll for covert 19
passes 3 million
india is facing a record rise in cases
people are terrified and angry if i'm
ill
if i'm sick where should i go what am i
supposed to do
the country now has the second highest
number of infections after the u.s
overtaking brazil where doctors say
they're having to tie patients down
in order to put them on ventilators
because they've run out of sedatives
the patient is subjected to a form of
torture and cannot even ask for help
when he or she feels uncomfortable
in the situation
[Music]
the president has been heavily
criticized for ignoring the science
and letting the crisis spiral
brazil is one of the countries
vaccinating its people through the world
health organization's
kovac scheme many scientists feel
wealthier nations
need to do more to help poorer countries
with jabs
in america where more people have died
from covid19 than anywhere else in the
world
over 200 million vaccine doses have now
been administered
but like many countries there are large
numbers of people reluctant to get a jab
we can see even recently with the
astrazeneca vaccine that people are
concerned about its use in some parts of
the world and that means that we are in
the
really regrettable situation in some
countries in some parts of africa
where we're seeing a rise of vaccine
hesitancy and this very precious and
scarce vaccine is now going to waste
the big fear is that covert will stay
one step ahead of us
mutating and even evading vaccines as
many countries struggle
to contain the surge of infections becky
cottrell
sky news